champion 2021 u.s chess champion wesley
so but by the way uh i i mean i just got
to say i i think he he played the best
check he deserved it i mean he was
undefeated throughout
the classical portion and he is the
repeat champion
as he comes into the studio
he got a better handshake from maurice
than from any one of his opponents i was
like wow
you're practicing you're prepping you're
practicing
okay we'll give maurice the wild card
we're talking about
i like that idea
[Laughter]
sharks like you in the water
right where i'm standing
first of all congratulations thank you
for winning the championship what does
it mean to win
also in back-to-back years that is not
something that's been done in quite some
time yeah it means a lot well first of
all i thank the lord jesus all glory to
him for
giving me the victory uh
i mean i got many people to thank also
especially uh first i'd like to thank
our
big chess supporters without which none
of this would be possible our rex and
jean is seeing field they're right there
outside i saw them watching the games
genie
i think i've only seen genie three times
here in st louis but it's always nice to
have it around very pleasant so
just the dedication that they give
also rex watching the games being here
every single day cheering out the
players
i think it's none of the other
supporters ever
maybe maybe there are a few but
very rare to see but yeah winning this
determines a lot it's time to celebrate
uh i wasn't actually expecting to be in
a playoffs today i think fabiano was
pushing and pushing his game yesterday
so
i was a bit disappointed if he won i
feel like i'm running out of energy also
in this tournament
and you saw him playing yesterday was
there a moment as you saw impressing
that you thought yeah it's over uh i've
got to let this one go yeah yeah that's
true nah we were my mom and i were
having dinner in the hotel and we were
following the games online but of course
the engines are very weak
so but it was giving like a winning
advantage for for fabiano after the
queen sack
uh so i thought fabiano was gonna push
it also sam was not playing his best in
this tournament so i thought it's over
it's done at that point but actually
later i looked at the game deeper and
fabiano was winning but it's a very
complicated win
so
and today anything can happen let me ask
you before we get to today the moment
you you found out that it was a drawing
it was clear to you that was a draw what
was your you're feeling like knowing
that the playoffs gave you a chance
today yeah i'm very happy it's like
giving me new life uh i thought the
tournament was pretty much over by
yesterday uh
fabian almost won three games in a row
well he won three games but not in a row
so
it just gave me a new a new bread of
life that this tournament might not be
over that i might still have some
chances
and uh yeah i'd like to thank sam for
saving that difficult game
and let's add to this one then today you
mean you've been sam shanklin yeah now
let's get to today
you play against fabi yeah and no bones
about it he came at you and you are on
your back in this first game with the
black pieces yeah yeah that's true well
first of all i think uh
i slept alright yesterday and i didn't
prepare anything i didn't look at any
chess i had a clear mind coming in i
just want to play fast also the time
control it's two second delay not
increments so time is very crucial here
so i just want to play fast and make
some good moves
uh but the thing i thought i had a very
comfortable position out of the opening
when he got double pawn so i i cannot
relax at that stage i knew he was gonna
go all out fabby plays for a win with
both callers so i knew he was gonna
go all out but somehow i misplayed the
position i i just
relaxed too early played some moves and
suddenly found myself in a very
difficult position uh and in the end
game
uh he probably missed a win somewhere
rook b1 instead of knight d5 was the the
moment as he as he played uh against you
would have been much more
uh
challenging after he sacrificed
on c6 yeah this game is so weird like i
don't even know what we're moving i
think we are making tons of mistakes in
the middle game but
so i was no idea what's going on but on
ic6 yeah i think uh
yeah i think rook b1 is not easy to play
i guess king c7 knight b5 is the point
exactly b6 i guess we both missed that i
think he had i mean it at this point i
think rp1 is not very clear because
rupee one kings is seven
knight d5 king c6 rook b6 king d7 bishop
b5 king c8 and i don't see a win for
white so knight b5
king takes rook b6 king d7 bishop b5
king c8 but maybe the end game is
winning like you can i don't know
take on f6 or something
my rook is very awfully placed yeah your
rook looks uh
especially in hospitable huh maybe rook
to b7 right now
king c6 rook f7 and then just take on f7
oh you cannot take on d5 that's the
problem yeah this is very clean yeah so
after b7 maybe i should go to d6 but
yeah i'm pretty sure
it's lost like in d7 or b7
in d6
king d6 and maybe maybe take on f6 right
now and then take on yeah but i think
the thing in this game i was playing
with no pressure like uh
i i didn't expect this play up so i was
just playing fast playing chess if
chances come good if i lose that's fine
too so
i'm absolutely just playing very calmly
and it paid off when did you feel wesley
that the tide had truly turned well when
i saw this when i put this knight on d6
i feel like i'm holding yeah like
because my seat pawn is very fast yeah
so so when i brought my knight to d6 i
feel like i i feel i'm pretty sure he
totally missed this knight c8 knight d6
idea he probably thought he was just
winning
yeah i think e4 was bad move because
maybe he had some other tries like rook
b1 but
yeah but when i got my knight to d6 i
feel like
the worst is over because such and also
later on like i wasn't thinking of
winning but
yeah here it's very unclear i thought
instead of king e3 i thought he had rook
b8 and rook g8
like f5
rb8 king c7 rook g8
looks much more
yeah but it's probably still it's
probably just a draw
yeah so
yeah better than the game yeah and i
think fabian i had no idea what was
going on and then
later in the game i looked at the club
and he had one second
right since this is uh delay you don't
gain any time so
and then next thing next thing i look
here he lost on time the arbiters
pointed out also right
then you obviously have to watch him
play against sam
and he managed to win that game which
was the best result for you because now
yeah now you knew that a draw was enough
assured of assured of even if i lose i i
will move on to the blitz right
and yeah so then the question became
how to approach a game that you know a
draw is enough how do you normally
approach that kind of situation or how
did you approach this one
well i uh
during the last few months i
prepared a repertoire for white with one
d4 when i only want to draw
so against all openings i played drawing
like i prepared drawing lines against
him so grandfather kings engine uh a
queen's gambit so
if i want to play safe i have a very
safe opening repertoire with one d4 so
it helps a lot that i'm white if black
anything can happen sam sebian is very
dangerous player also i saw his
interview yesterday and he said that
with black he tends to prepare solid
openings and stuff so that's very
comfortable with d4 i know he has to
play some dutch kings engine so when he
played what he played at some point it
seemed like you switched gears and said
i'm just going to be aggressive
particularly before
at that point you were it looks like you
thought you had a great position and you
wanted to win
uh well i don't i didn't want to win i
just want to throw in
okay but the the worst thing happened is
i relax and then the position becomes
slightly more difficult well i know he
could play something like this knight d7
but i also knew that he's not very
experienced in such positions
and in playing king's indian structures
you need tons of experience which
i think sam is not very familiar with
this knights here also knight d7 knight
e7 looks a bit dubious
and i think how i played with rook e1
bishop f1 is very solid
and i get queen side play so i think i
didn't run into any problems
in this game again you're the champ uh
back to back championships does that
matter to you yeah it matters a lot uh
i think i remember 2017 i really wanted
to win my first uh championship because
it was
getting more and more difficult uh and i
wasn't sure if i was going to win it but
uh now this is my third title and uh
and it's huge
i feel like the youth championship is
one of the tournaments that we have to
play every single year and winning the
title is huge it's even more important
than the money
all right well congratulations you won
the title and the money you're the 2021
u.s champion yeah i must i must say that
today in the tie bricks with two games
and 10 seconds anything could happen i
think fabi should have won today
considering how well he played but
but yeah today is my day
it was indeed wesley first of all
congratulations you came here in the
studio after your game against dania
nordisk dejected how did you turn the
tide at that point
i just moved on and for and forgot about
it that was
really painful
not because i would have moved the plus
three and also the rating and stuff
would be number six in the world and all
that
but
i
i think it happens to everyone that's
that's the game of chess there's not one
player which have missed chances uh in
this tournament so i guess i look at it
like like a sportsman like in basketball
you can miss your shots or in football
you can miss your throws
uh i i think in chess that's just part
of the game that's why you just need to
keep getting better and improving and
improving and know that they're always
going to be instances which
you're going to miss
i mean yeah it it's hard but uh you need
to move on to the next game
the mindset of a champion absolutely
yeah
by the way
you are wrong on one thing
you said you thought plus three was
going to win the championship it turned
out plus two
wasn't enough yeah this is crazy yeah i
think uh
it's never happened before where place
to won a championship 2017 i was plus
three with uh with alexander nischuk and
i tied for first
but
i i think
yep this never happened before i think
linear fabi myself also shankle and
jeffrey so all 2700s were out of form in
this tournament as you can see but also
the championship is getting stronger
every single year like next year we'll
have levon so you can't really compare
2012 championships from yes sir plus two
winning the championship in your memory
i think once michael wilder it was a
very very very soft tournament somehow
nobody could
could pull away but it's very very rare
wesley i just simply wanted to say
congratulations yeah uh celebrate your
victory it was very well deserved yeah
thank you so much yesterday you got it
totally unexpected
yeah maybe next year you
one of you can can can play again i mean
i look at them
i look at their games
if you want to take a break
actually wesley anytime you want we got
a hot seat right over here you wanna you
can play the car in english
we'll send uh he's already preparing for
you right yeah we're gonna send maurice
first
give him a good
give him a good send off yeah i don't
know what opening morris please
and you won't and
congratulations again thank you guys
and as uh wesley started his interview
with a thanks and a big shout out to
each and everybody as we get to see a
repeat
of how he won
the finishing touches we also want to
give a shout out to so many people
behind the scenes here at the st louis
chess club at scholastic center that
makes these broadcasts possible
start us off christian absolutely well
the guys and ladies at spectrum studios
of course randy kevin marcus brian baby
jan who takes care of us